[موسيقى]
هكذا بدل احتفال بالاسير المحرر كريم يونس
هنا في بلدته عاره بعد ان قضى اربعين سنه
في السجون الاسرائيليه قبل اشهر فقط فقد
والدته وبدا وكان العالم قد تغير تماما
بنظره وقد يحتاج وقتا للتالم
من بلد لا تشبه البلد لنا اليوم شايف لكن
احنا بنعتبر انه يعني وجودنا بالسجن هو
محطه نظليه وانتقلنا من مرحله الى مرحله
وحولت اسرائيل من على الفرحه بتحريره
وتركه في شوارع مدينه يهوديه فجرا الا ان
اعدادا كبيره من الفلسطينيين وصلوا الى
هنا للمشاركه في فرحه تحريره من بينهم
زملاء سابقون له في الزنزانه واقارب لم
يرونه من قبل
وتعرفت عليه
بالسجن سعود جدا صعب لما اول نظره له اول
اول ما قبضته وشفته همم طريقنا عارف عن
حالي انا من الاردن واول مره بزور فلسطين
كتب كريم في رساله اهداها لشعبه بعد خروجه
قائلا ها انا قد عدت متقلا ب 40 سنه من
الاسر بقليل من الشعر الاشيب ولكنني عدت
بعد ان تحول الى ايقونه فلسطينيه وكان
عميد الاسرى الفلسطينيين لم تكتفي الحكومه
اليمنيه الجديده ب 40 عاما من السجن
وسارعت الى التلويح بسحب جنسيتك كريم يونس
وابعاده الى قطاع غزه لا نقول غازي من
قريتي عاره العربيه